Single mothers raise criminals.
Single mothers raise the worst kids on the planet.
Single mother. Single mother.
Yeah well how about you're so fucking busy arguing with your husband
whilst talk about what your fucking kids turn out like.
All the fucking therapy that your kids need,
all the fucking re evaluating
of what a real relationship should fucking look like.
Cause they've been watching your fucked up ass fucking marriage
all those years. Let's talk about that.
Stop talking about the fucking criminal rate of children
that were raised by single mothers.
Cause there's mad fucking criminals in the world
that were raised by ugly ass people
that stayed married when they shouldn't have.
So quit fucking focusing on single mothers.
Cause I'm positive that the people who found those statistics
and we're doing that study
weren't doing it
so you could throw it in a fucking single mother's face
and be like your kids gonna be a criminal.
It wasn't some fucking clap back to single mothers.
I'm sure it was to show the support areas where there could be
where we could inject more love and support.
Not fucking criticism and judgement.
Cause it's probably an ugly shitty marriage
setting ugly shitty example.
Don't feel bad cause you're a single mom.